those true moderates The Independents
the swing voters out there in America
they want nothing to do with this guy
they're sick of it
they're saying he's too caustic
he's too bombastic he's got too much
baggage
I mean
he's not due back in court until
December
but under New York state law the
prosecution has to be ready to go to
trial within six months of issuing the
indictments
so even though he's not due back till
December at that point the prosecution
legally has to be ready to go
so we could get a trial during the
Republican primary we could get a trial
before the 2024 election
and that's not going to play well with
those moderates and independents